>> Dave Weitz: Welcome
to tonight's lecture.
It's gonna be a fun lecture.
Pia and
l were talking about this just before,
we each agreed that there are certain
things that were both passionate about and
we're trying to teach
the classes about that.
So l am very passionate about foams and
emulsion cuz that what we'll hear about
today, that's what I do some research on.
So that's one of the themes of this week.
So who's been to these lectures before?
Most people, who hasn't been?
Okay, watch carefully.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Dave Weitz: So we always have a quiz.
And remember the traditions in this
class when we see an equation.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: This apron has all of
the equations from one of
the years of the class on it.
So you get to wear this, so you put up
your hand and you answer the question.
I'll try and pick somebody.
But I get to read the question before.
It's based on last week's lecture.
So the heat diffusion
coefficient determines how fast
heat moves into a material.
Why is it more or
less the same for all foods?
Back there,
the one who's looking behind, you.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Dave Weitz: Pardon?
>> Dave Weitz: What does that mean?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Dave Weitz: So what's food
mainly made of?
Very good.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: Okay,
a little freebie science lesson.
If you take a part of water and
heat it from the bottom,
does it heat up by diffusion?
No, how do you know that?
What's the one thing
that you absolutely know?
If I took a piece of meat
the size of pot of water,
how long will it take to cook it?
>> Several hours.
>> Dave Weitz: Several hours.
How long does it take
to boil a pot of water?
>> Few minutes.
>> Dave Weitz: Few minutes,
so what's happening?
It's convection.
The difference in the weight and the
density of the water causes it to stir.
So it's not diffusion.
Okay, chef Gordy from
last week made a liquid
distill that turned into a solid
when poured onto a plate.
How did that happen way back?
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Dave Weitz: Super cool,
super cold water is very super cool,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Dave Weitz: Very good, so
super cold water.
You don't allow the ice
crystals to nucleate,
So it doesn't form ice even though
you cool it below the freezing point.
Then when you pour it,
it freezes instantaneously.
Last quiz.
Jeff Gordy made cigar flavor ice cream,
how did he get the smoke into
the ice cream?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Dave Weitz: He
whipped the cream of smoke.
Okay, that's gonna be something
we will talk about today.
What does that mean?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Dave Weitz: Air goes into the cream to
make the ice cream filled with air.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: In fact, in fact,
that's what the topic of today.
This is what I get.
That's the topic of today.
It's creams, ice cream.
It's really a foam.
And so
we're gonna talk about foam this week.
Here's my favorite kind of foam.
I tried to buy some,
that's why I was late.
I tried to buy some outside and they said
they make it but it didn't foam up enough.
So fortunately, Pia got some and so
we always like to have some
demonstration during this class.
So we have a demonstration,
can we do this now?
Look at that.
This is a foam.
Let me take it from here.
You can pass it around, don't drink
it all of it, if you take a zip.
Okay, what is the foam?
It's bubble of gas inside the fluid,
the gas doesn't go into the fluid you
have to made bubbles of it and so
foam is a really cool thing.
Can I have my slide?
So this is one of my favorite
foams on top of a coffee.
Notice this one though.
Notice this one.
It's getting really solid like, right?
So this is sort of what
I find really amazing.
What have you done?
You took gas.
Gas goes everywhere.
And you took fluid.
Fluid flows everywhere.
And you mixed them together.
Gas and a liquid and you get a solid,
how is that possible?
So if you look inside, you see that
the form is made up of bubbles,
bubbles of air, why does it get solid?
If you pack it enough, if you start to
pack it, the bubbles start reforms and
it's the deformation of
the bubbles that make it solid.
So here's different degrees of solidity,
this is just a little bit of wet milk
essentially, it's clearly a fluid.
This is the foam on top of a latte,
this is a whip cream,
same thing, it's just air and
cream and this is a shaving cream.
It's even more solid.
So what's happening?
Well, you can go back and
you can see it here.
The more you pack the bubbles together,
the more you pack them,
the more solid they get.
But,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: The degree of packing
depends on what we call the volume
fraction of the bubbles and you know that.
You know that,
in fact, if you remember what Pia showed
us, the bubbles were well separated.
If they're well separated, they move
freely in the fluid and it's just a fluid.
You have to pack them enough
until they start to deform.
So you have to pack them so much until
they actually begin to deform and
that doesn't happen if there's
spherical and they're the same size.
It doesn't happen until
the volume fraction reaches 64%.
That's a magic number,
it's a well defined number and
we can measure it but
there's no way of actually predicting it.
Even to this day,
it's a well known number, but
nobody can actually predict it.
This is true only for
spherical objects of uniform size.
And, so, the more you pack them,
the stiffer they get.
But the stiffness doesn't start
until you're above this value.
And so the elasticity or
the stiffness of the foam will go
from something that has no stiffness,
no elastic properties to
something that barely is elastic.
And then as you increase the volume
fraction above this critical value,
it becomes more and more elastic.
And we can capture that,
by a simple equation which is shown here.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: And the important features
are it only has a value, a positive value,
when the volume fraction is above
this critical value here and
it depends on the surface tension.
That's the stiffness of the surface.
It's like how stiff a balloon is and
inversely with the size of the bubbles.
If I make the bubbles smaller,
it gets stiffer.
There's another kind of mixture and
we'll hear a lot about that today as well.
That behaves very much like a foam.
A foam I take air, and
I mix it with water.
If I take a second fluid and mix it
with a fluid, two admissible fluids,
like oil and water,
normally they don't mix.
If I wanna mix them, I get a mixture
of drops of one into the other and
that's an emulsion.
A mayonnaise or an aioli is an emulsion.
Whipped cream, or coffee foam, is a foam.
This has air drops inside
of a continuous fluid.
This has water drops or
fluid drops inside a continuous fluid.
And if you look at a microscope
image of this, this is a mayonnaise,
this is actually just Hellman's
mayonnaise, and if you look at it,
you can see the drops of
the oil inside of the water.
Same with aioli.
Aioli is made with garlic,
a little bit of lemon juice,
some salt to draw the water
out at the garlic.
And then you emulsify,
you make drops of olive oil inside of it.
So how do make the drops?
And how do they stable?
Why do they stable?
Well you can make them just by,
essentially, either mixing two fluids
together, or mixing air with a fluid.
You can do it by whisking or blending.
And emersion blender will see some
examples with Corey tonight of how he does
it in a restaurant.
What happens when you mix fluids or
air together when they wanna cross
each other they're sheer, there's torn
apart and they break into smaller drops.
And you mix more and more, you make
them into smaller and smaller drops.
What happens if I make the drops smaller?
Do you remember?
Stiffness goes up.
It gets more elastic.
And why do they stay stable?
Normally, so a good example, one of the
most common examples, is a vinaigrette.
You mix olive oil and vinegar,
you shake them up they will miscible,
you shake them up you get drops.
If you do that, just with the oil and
vinegar, and you put it down, they will
rapidly face upright, they are all rapidly
go back to the oil and the vinegar.
But if you add a little flavor in,
people like to add mustard for example,
little mustard powder.
Add a little mustard powder,
a little mustard, you mix them up,
it adds some taste, but
it also keeps them stable.
And keeps them from separating.
And the reason for that is that the
mustard acts as what we call a surfactant.
A surfactant is surface active.
Surfactant, surface active molecule.
It's a molecule that's half and half.
It's half water-like,
and it's half oil-like,
half hydrophilic, half hydrophobic.
It can't decide what it wants to be,
so it always stays at the interphase.
And if it stays at the interphase,
the role of the surfactant is
actually to stabilize the drops.
Because if you have a coating of
surfactant, and I think we show it here.
That keeps the drops
from emerging together.
As they come closer,
the surfactant prevents the drops
from touching one another.
So the role of the surfactant,
in an emulsion, or a foam,
is to stabilize the drops.
so a real alioli is just garlic,
a little lemon juice,
some salt, crush the garlic,
you draw the water out of the garlic,
tiny, tiny,
tiny amount of water and
a huge amount of olive oil.
And you emulsify the olive
oil inside that water.
No surfactant except from
the surfactant from the garlic,
which is not a great surfactant.
But now what people do
is they use egg yolk
because that is a wonderful surfactant.
And so we had a little contest.
We asked, how much emulsion, how much
mayonnaise can you make with egg yolk?
Anybody have a idea
theoretically how much it is?
It's a huge amount, huge amount.
Here, somebody this was
in one of our course,
somebody made nearly a litre
of mayo from one yolk.
Actually there's enough surfactant
to make probably ten times
that amount of emulsion,
because egg yolk is a fabulous surfactant.
Okay, so tonight we have Corey Lee
from Benu Restaurant in San Francisco,
I had the real pleasure to do
something with him before.
And so
I know a lot of the things he makes.
And he's gonna tell us about his menu,
which is just filled with foams and
emulsions.
So Cory.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Thanks Dave, and
thanks Pia for inviting me out.
I'm really excited to be here.
As Dave mentioned, I'm from San Francisco.
I'm a chef and
restaurateur in San Francisco.
I operate three restaurants
in San Francisco.
One is called Mr. Benjamin.
It's a very casual French bistro.
The other one is called Institu, which
is a restaurant that I opened last year,
and that's kind of an interesting project
where we collaborate with over 100 chefs
around the world.
And they pick a dish from their repertoire
and they show us how to make that dish,
and we execute that at the museum.
So it's kind of like a food exhibition,
so to speak.
And then the third restaurant is Benno,
where I spend most of my time.
And Beno is a resturaunt
that I opened in 2010.
At the time I had been working as a chef
for 15 years, I started cooking in 1995.
And all my experience up to that
point was in Western kitchens or
French restaurants, or
at least French based restaurants.
And my last position right before I start
up and it was at the restaurant called
the French Laundry in Napa Valley For
the great American chef Thomas Keller.
And that's a restaurant that
I think is very iconic.
And known worldwide for
being one of the first kind of fine dining
restaurants in America to have
an American perspective, and
not just try to replicate French cuisine.
And because I was the chef there I had a
lot of responsibility that had to do with
menu development and creating new dishes
and making sure that the cuisine evolved.
And that was really rewarding, but
there was also kind of this growing
curiosity to explore some different
kinds of flavors and techniques.
And those are the flavors and
techniques really of my native culture.
And of Asian cuisine in general.
So that's something that I became more and
more interested in.
But at the same time I knew it wasn't
the right restaurant for that.
People go to Napa Valley, they're at
a restaurant called French Laundry,
they wanna have that cuisine,
the last thing they want is some
kind of Asian influence in that.
But still, as that curiosity grew,
I realized more and
more that I needed to
do something on my own.
And that was really the impetus for
going out and opening Benu.
Has anyone here ever been to Benu?
There are people here.
Okay, great.
But I figured most of you hadn't been,
so this is a little video that can kinda
give you a look into our restaurant, okay.
[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Thank you.
So Dave mentioned that we're going to
talk a lot about foams and emulsions.
And okay, so something that we think a lot
about at Benu is is texture and
mouth feel.
A lot of people think about how something
tastes to decide whether they like
something or not, but
I look at it with three things in mind.
One is the taste of course.
Another is the aroma,
which is incredibly important.
And the last is texture.
So if you think of a food that you really,
really like or you really don't like.
And if you were to just
close your nose and
just put that food on your palate, I think
you'd find you'd have a pretty different
experience with that food
you either like or dislike.
And that's important texture is in
how we perceive a certain food.
So that's something we think a lot
about and to that we go about
that in a lot of ways, but it's a texture
that we want to be deliberate about.
So sometimes it's a choice
of the ingredients.
So if we're making it a chicken broth or
a dish with chicken soup, for
example, we might put
some chicken feet and
chicken wings so that you get this
really gelatinous mouth feel,
maybe with vegetables, a potato,
we might fry it versus steaming it,
versus poaching it, and
impart a different texture.
Sometimes we actually intentionally
overcook things to get a certain texture.
But the texture is
really really important.
Another way we do that is actually
by engineering like a system,
which is what Dave is referring to.
And two of those are foams and emulsions.
So when I was looking at our menu, and
this is our menu from I don't
know three or four weeks ago,
getting ready to talk about this,
I asked myself okay, this is our menu.
They asked if I can talk about foams and
emulsions,
which is not really something I do often.
But let me see how many emulsions we have.
So I went down the list and that's how
many emulsions that we have on the menu.
So I was kind of surprised.
I said, okay,
maybe I can actually do this talk.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: And then I asked myself,
okay, well, how many foams do we have?
And then it was this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: So now I feel like an expert
on foams and emulsions, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: And there are only two
dishes on the menu that doesn't have
a foam or an emulsion in some form.
So I'm just gonna video demo these
dishes that have foams and emulsions.
Don't worry,
we're not gonna do all of them.
We're gonna do these because I think
they're different kinds of foams and
emulsions.
Okay, so
I'll go through these one by one and
then you can see the various ways
we incorporate foams and emulsions.
But keep in mind that as a chef, there
are certainly different kinds of chefs and
different ways to go about it,
but I don't look at a dish and
tell myself let's put a foam on there or
an emulsion,
I try to create some kind of experience
for the guest who's having this dish and
then work backwards and
see how we can achieve that.
And in that sense I think it's like if
your were to think about building a house
or designing a building, and
then there's all this engineering behind
it that gives that structure support and
allows it to happen.
And that's how I kinda see working with
foams and emulsions in our kitchen.
So The first dish is a little soup,
1,000 year old quail egg which
is basically a base cooked egg, or pidan,
or century egg it goes by different names.
Potage is a soup and
that's where the emulsion will be and
then ginger is pickled ginger,
some acidity that pairs well and
classically with
the thousand year old egg.
So, Dave you want to join me here and
maybe help
explain some of these things that I do?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Corey Lee: So this is basically bacon
rendering out in a lot of butter.
So a ton of fat coming
out of here [LAUGH].
>> Dave Weitz: What is on top?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Corey Lee: Says onion cabbage.
We're basically making a simple soup.
And I don't think you think
of a soup as an emulsion.
But I'm sure all of you have had
a soup that's really greasy.
To me, that's not an unemulsified soup.
And what gives you kind
of the velvety texture of
a nice made soup is that it's an emulsion.
And the fat is evenly
disbursed in that system.
So here we're adding chicken stock,
we're letting that cook.
So we'll cook that until it's soft.
Is that a foam?
>> Dave Weitz: That's a foam, but
it's made of an emulsion.
>> Corey Lee: Okay, so
now we're pureeing the whole thing.
Some seasoning and then we add a little
bit of whey protein to help emulsify it.
And then, you can see it almost turn into
this very thick mayonaisse-y like texture.
That's just a little bit of cayenne.
But there's a point where it emulsified
and becomes almost like pudding.
And, [COUGH] and
it started to happen right around here.
So this is the thousand-year-old
quail egg that I was talking about.
This is basically a base cooked egg.
We brine it for a couple of weeks
in a solution of lye and puer tea.
And then we age it for another four weeks.
And basically what happens is it
turns into this kind of wobbly gel
with a very creamy, kind of sticky
yoke texture which is this here.
It taste a lot better than it
looks trust me [LAUGH].
>> Corey Lee: So
this a ginger sour cream which is
an infusion of ginger and sour cream.
And then this is the potage.
And this is a little bit of cooked
cabbages that have been juiced to kind of
echo the cooked cabbage in the soup,
but kind of a fresh version of that.
And then we serve that with
the thousand-year-old quail
egg.
>> Dave Weitz: So
the sour cream is itself an emulsion.
And then he's made
an emulsion on top of this.
So this is an emulsion
on an emulsion [LAUGH].
>> Corey Lee: So that is the first dish.
>> Corey Lee: [APPLAUSE] Okay, so
this second dish is an oyster
pork belly in kimchi,
so this is kind of a fun version of
a classic pairing in Korean cuisine.
Really here it's the kimchi
that we first ferment,
and we make a stock, and we do
a couple of different things for that.
So the first thing is, making kind of
like, it's basically like a quick kimchi.
I wanna make kimchi this way if I was
actually going to serve the kimchi itself.
But we start with cabbage,
some dried chili powder,
just a little bit of anchovy essence.
And then we actually ferment this.
In a bag.
So the fermentation
happens pretty quickly.
It takes about three or four days.
We actually don't serve this
because the texture of this and
the flavor of this is really not really
good, but when you make a stock with it,
it's actually very powerful and very
strong, so that's why we make it this way.
So all we're doing is taking that kimchi,
covering it with a little bit of water,
and then simmer it.
And then we get this very intense,
spicy, sour flavored liquid.
Okay, so that liquid is the base for
two things that we do for this dish.
The first thing that we do is
add a little bit of starch and
we lay it out on these acetate sheets.
And then we get even layer that dries and
right before it's fully dried,
we're able to cut it into precise squares.
So that's the squares and then it's still
has some moisture so it's appliable so
we can take that and put it into
a mold make a little cup out of it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: And then once it's
in that shape we dry it
further until it's crispy.
So that's the kimchi cup.
The other part of the kimchi juice that we
made, we make a gel using a jgelling gum,
and then we basically set it to gel and
then puree it.
And we're pureeing this with a few things.
One is
a bit of soy lecithin some different
seasonings, and a little bit of skim milk.
So this looks like a really
really thick puree and it is, but
the reason why we do that is so
that we can whip it into a foam.
And one thing about this dish that's
important is that we have this hot
pork belly with this ice cold oyster.
And that's something that we wanted to try
to maintain even in a really small bite.
So we take that puree.
We put it into a kitchen mixer.
And we whip it until it's really,
really dense like shaving cream
So you can see how thick that gets.
And this is just a single we should have,
we gonna put it up, [SOUND]
Well we're just trimming it up so it fits
in the cup, but then in the cup, [LAUGH]
It's too big, so in the cup we take a
little bit of the rendered pork belly, and
we make a powder, and we add hot pork
belly and kimchi that's mixed together,
and then we add the foam
that separates the hot pork
belly from the cold oyster.
>> Dave Weitz: See how
solid it is?
>> Corey Lee: Yeah.
So that's the oyster, pork belly kimchi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Okay.
>> Dave Weitz: So
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dave Weitz: What I find really cool
is that you can make something that's so
solid just starting with a liquid, and
mixing gas into it.
>> Corey Lee: Yeah,
I think it's pretty cool.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Dave Weitz: It's cool, it keeps
the heat apart.
>> Corey Lee: So
the next thing is this sausage.
And I was not sure if this was really an
emotion, I had to ask Dave this morning.
[LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: But I know it's okay.
>> Dave Weitz: We define it
as being an emulsion in this class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Dave Weitz: Actually it is.
>> Corey Lee: So this is another
kind of surf and turf kind of dish.
A little small snack that, this is
all little snacks before you start.
The food is not this small for
most of the meal.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: So this is a fermented
pepper sauce that we make
>> Corey Lee: It's fermented pepper based
and we add different seasonings, and
then we add sesame oil at the end.
And it's kind of like a thick,
kind of really spicy sauce,
but we just use a drop of it.
This is what an emulsion is.
So we take pork and we add aromatics,
ginger, scallion, garlic,
green scallions and
we add mung bean jelly noodles and
sweet rice, and we mix it altogether,
and that's the base.
And this is all pork blood.
So we're making the base of
a pork sausage or boudin noir.
And to this mixture,
we emulsify sesame oil, and
sorry, this is some other seasoning mix.
I don't think that's really
important at this point.
But after this step,
we emulsify the sesame oil, and
you end up with an emulsified sausage.
And I don't know how many of you have made
sausages before, but sometimes you make
a sausage and then you go to cook it,
and all this fat comes out, right?
And it's really dry and
the texture's not good, and
that's from the sausage breaking.
But this one, well,
you can see how thick it is here.
>> Dave Weitz: So what's interesting here,
Cory, is not only is it an emulsion,
but it's filled with solid particles.
So that's the one thing
I didn't talk about.
I talked gas, bubbles, liquid drops.
You can also have solid particles in
the fluid, and that's called a suspension.
This is the third of the three different
classes of materials like this.
>> Corey Lee: So after its cooked,
you can see that its retained its shape.
And we can actually saute this
without it rendering out all of
the oil that we emulsified in.
This is a little bit of squid,
and we just square that squid so
we can wrap it around the blood sausage.
And then we gently poach it so
that it's almost raw, but
it's just a little bit further because
it's been cooked and it crawls out.
This is that fermented pepper
sauce we had in the beginning,
the port sausage or the blood sausage.
And then some pickled radishes,
sesame leaf,
a bit more of that spicy sauce.
The squid goes right on top, and
then it gets glazed with a pork and
squid flavored sauce.
Okay, so that's the squid.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Okay, this is a fun dish,
because it has both a foam and
an emotion, right?
That's super exciting, so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: We start here with
something that you saw when Dave was
talking about, which is the mayonnaise.
Now, I realized I only need to use
20 grams of this egg yolk now,
but this is three egg yolks.
Some horseradish juice,
mustard, some seasoning,
basic mayonnaise flavor with-
>> Dave Weitz: So that's 20 grams?
>> Corey Lee: It's a little bit more, but
this is about 500 grams of oil.
>> Dave Weitz: So at most 50 grams?
500 grams of oil and 50 grams for
everything else.
>> Corey Lee: So
you can see this come together, and
you can just see how thick this gets.
Yeah, it comes together fairly quickly
But also,
the only water in there is the vinegar and
the horseradish juice, so-
>> Dave Weitz: And
a little bit from the egg, yeah.
So you can see that roughly speaking,
it's 50 grams of water at most and
500 grams of oil.
That's roughly one in ten.
So it was roughly 90% by volume through
the drop phase, which is the oil phase.
That's why it's so stiff.
It's way up on the stiff side.
>> Corey Lee: So here,
I'm making a little batter.
So this is a corn starch batter for
a tempura.
And when I was coming up on being
trained on how to make a tempura,
people had this thing where they
used club soda in the batter.
And you put that club soda batter in
a fryer, and it kind of explodes, right?
And then in about ten years ago,
when I was working with some siphons,
l realized l can just make that soda
in a charger and do it last second.
And so that's a batter that we use,
which is basically a charge of CO2.
The batter goes in, and
the batter itself is a foam.
So this is dried jellyfish that we're
coating in a little bit of starch
just to help adhere the batter to it.
And then we kinda lay it
out into these strands,
and basically wrap a shrimp or
use the jellyfish to wrap the shrimp.
Has everyone here tried dried jellyfish?
Highly recommend it, it's very good.
And it has a snappy texture that kinda
enhances the crispiness of the batter.
So what we do is we'll wrap
that around the shrimp.
And then we'll discharge a little
bit of that batter that was
in the soda charger with carbon dioxide.
And then-
>> Dave Weitz: There's
the foam.
>> Corey Lee: Yeah.
And then we'll fry that for a minute,
just to get it crispy and cook the shrimp,
But it ends up being a very,
very flaky batter.
And I assume that has a lot to do with the
gas that's trapped in there, right, Dave?
>> Dave Weitz: Mm-hm.
>> Corey Lee: So we get a nice piece of
fried shrimp, season it.
We glaze it a little bit with this kind
of sweet, spicy horseradish syrup.
And then this is some of that
mayonnaise that we made,
the horseradish flavored mayonnaise.
A little bit of chili powder,
And some cilantro leaves.
This is just gold flakes,
just because gold flakes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: And then some fresh grated
horseradish.
And then the jellyfish itself is
just kinda little fried shrimp with
a dipping mayonnaise.
Okay, that's the jellyfish.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Thank you.
>> Corey Lee: Okay, so
this next one is actually a dish that
I wanted to do today, because Dave and
I did something with this when he
visited San Francisco a few years ago.
What did we talk about at that time?
>> Dave Weitz: We talked about
the elasticity of the shell.
>> Corey Lee: We mentioned the elasticity,
right?
>> Dave Weitz: Exactly, so
I'll show you this, and then I'll tell you
a little story from my perspective of this
shark fin.
>> Corey Lee: So,
this is just to kinda identify
the things to look for.
The egg white in this dish
is actually a custard, so
there's many ways to make a custard.
This is an egg white custard,
and that's the emotion.
We take some ham stock, and
we emulsify that to it,
and that becomes a cooked
egg white custard.
But here, we're making a broth.
That's associated with shark fins.
So shark fin soup,
those is a faux shark fin soup right?
This is not real shark fin.
So we make a soup that's flavored with
that kind of traditional
flavors of shark fin soup.
And two, we add some locust bean gum,
and alginate and
we extrude it into this calcium vat
to get these gels, gel noodles.
And then we cut them at a sharp bias to
get strands that look like shark fin.
And anyone who's ever had shark fin soup,
it's really a textural experience.
And the flavor is really about the broth.
And it was kind of like a, kind of
a fun dish that we did when we open.
We've done it in different iterations.
But that's the shark fin that we're
serving.
>> Dave Weitz: So
this is really a gel that Cory made and
he told me that he spent about a year and
a half to experiment,
to get the texture just right.
So, he says that mouth fill and
texture is very important.
>> Corey Lee: So, this is the custard mix
that we are making, that was the ham
stock that we made, we passed that,
we combine it with some egg whites,
some seasoning.
And then we add, sorry,
we're about to seam the custard right now.
So this is some Dungeness Crab
which is a local bay area crab or
a Pacific Northwest crab.
And then this is some of that.
And when we were mixing that with the egg
white, there's a lot of air trapped in it.
So we actually put that in a vacuum
sealer to remove the air, so it's a foam.
And we're actually trying to
get the air out of the foam,
so that you don't end up with
bubbles in your custard.
And then, this is some of that soup
that we turned into noodles, but
it's also a glaze,
a very rich chicken flavored soup.
And then we add some luxurious
stuff back in like Jinhua ham, and
black truffles because we
are doing a fake shark fin so
we wanna include some kind
of special ingredients.
And if you look at those strands they
actually look just like a real shark fin,
and on the palate as well.
They have a snap, and a texture to them
that's really similar to raw shark fin.
So that's the shark fin with Jinhua ham,
egg white, and black truffle.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Okay, so this one is bread.
And it's kind of It's kinda interesting,
I think Hal McGee did a lecture
here a few times, a couple times.
And he wrote an interesting
article about how great is a foam.
And I don't think as a chef you
go around and you're cooking and
you're like, there's a foam,
there's a mushroom,
there's that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Corey Lee: When you start to think
about it that way,
it's really interesting.
And basically, it helps you to
understand a lot of what is happening.
There's a certain kind of crust and
a certain kind of crumb and
certainly a certain kind of flavor that
we are looking for in our bread and
they are actually all related.
So the gas that's being produced by you
proofing the bread is also allowing for
a different kind of flavor, or
the flavors changing as those
gases are being released.
By baking something that
has more air in it,
you're getting a different type of
crumb and a different type of crust.
So we started with just some
starter grade flour and water.
And then we added the starter,
and we let that proof.
And you can see that its quite elastic,
and you can almost see how airy it is.
It's very wet.
It's kind of like a batter
more than it is a dough.
And then we'll put it into
these little bread molds, and
we'll let that proof for
about five to six hours.
And then you can see how it rises and how
much gas is being produced in that foam.
This is that same amount after
its proofed and then we bake it.
After it's baked,
is that still considered a foam?
>> Dave Weitz: It's a solid
foam.
>> Corey Lee: Solid foam.
>> Dave Weitz: So the outside of a liquid
form is a liquid surrounding the bubbles,
but if you solidify it, which you
do when you bake, it becomes a solid form.
>> Corey Lee: So
here, were making the butter
that comes with it.
So we start with a little bit of water and
we do this at,
you can see, 37 degrees Celcius.
We basically make a butter
that is still emulsified and
we can pour into these little molds
that kind of look like honeycomb.
So there's an emulsion here as well.
But this is the butter
after it's been set.
[SOUND]
>> Dave Weitz: Just like a solid foam,
it solidified the continuous phase,
which in this case,
is the foil.
>> Corey Lee: So
this is solid emotion basically, right?
>> Dave Weitz: Yeah,
yeah.
>> Corey Lee: And
then we drizzle some honey that's been
infused with ginsing on a honey comb.
It's basically honey butter, you know.
And then when we cut the bread open,
you can see, I guess the solid foam and
you can see the air or
the gas that was inside of it.
Yeah, see all of
those pockets?
So that is the sprouted
grain bread with honey and
ginseng.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Okay, does everyone
know what xiaolongbao is?
It's like a soup dumpling or
Shanghainese dumpling.
I decided to do this dish today because,
one,
there's actually a foam in the batter,
or the dough, just like the bread.
But it's actually,
we're taking, basically,
the opposite approach to the blood
sausage, which was an emulsified sausage.
And we're intentionally making a sausage
that's not emulsified to get a certain
effect.
So we start with this filling, and
this is lobster and shrimp being ground.
To this we make a lobster consume, or
lobster stock, and turn that into a gel.
And we grind that as well.
We also take clarified butter,
and grind that as well.
Everything gets mixed with lobster coral.
So you have almost equal parts
of the clarified butter,
this gel that you see going through.
In the top,
you can see that it's this brown gel.
That's the lobster stock, and
then we roll them into these little balls.
So right now,
they kind of look like a sausage, right?
Just like the blood sausage, or
it's all suspended in emulsion.
And then this is the dough, and we use a
yeast dough because we want to air it and
when you bite into it,
it's softer than a cold dough.
And that allows you go get some strength
in the dough and it can be thicker.
But when you bite into it,
it's not this hard, firm wrapper.
So this is dough,
after we've sheeted a few times, and
we punch these little circles,
and then we roll them thinner
to get the sides a little bit thinner
because that's the part that gets pleated.
And then we roll and we put inside of it
the parts that we made or the filling,
which is basically the sausage that
we want to break when we cook it,
or we want to separate into liquid and
fat when we cook it.
So,
After we steam it, we serve it on this
thing, so that's how it gets served.
But if you never had one before, I think
the next shot will kind of give you
an idea of what it's
like when you eat one.
So you have this dumpling that's
like super, super hot, and
then you bite into it, and then you expect
it to be like sausage filling like most
dumplings, but when you actually
bite into and break the skin,
you get this huge rush of hot, well,
in this case, clarified butter and
lobster consomme that just kinda gushes
out and it's just kind of a really
impactful bite.
>> Dave Weitz: That's
when you break the emulsion.
You cause the drops to coalesce.
And that's what he's done when he's
heated, and so it's no longer an emulsion,
it's just a mixture.
>> Corey Lee: Okay, so
that's the lobster xiaolongbao.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Thank you.
Okay, so this is the last dish, and
this is kind of like a sweet dessert.
And this starts off with, when you
guys think about a foam in food, for
me the first thing, I don't know,
what is the first thing I think about?
What is the first thing you think
about, Dave?
>> Dave Weitz: Depends.
If it's in the morning,
I think of the foam on top of a coffee,
if it's in the evening,
I think of foam on top of a beer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Dave Weitz: How about you?
>> Corey Lee: I think of a meringue.
That's the first thing that comes to mind.
>> Dave Weitz: You have a sweet tooth.
>> Corey Lee: And really, a macaroon.
So this is a French style meringue.
First, we made the egg whites, and
now we are whipping separately the cream,
and then we combine the cream and
the egg whites, so
we have two foams being mixed together
>> Corey Lee: And here,
we have creme fraiche,
which is basically like sour cream.
And we add gelatin to that,
and we mix that in,
trying to maintain as much
of the air as possible.
Try to keep it as light as possible.
And then,
we pipe it into these little half-dome or
half-sphere molds, and then, we freeze it.
And the reason why we want it to be airy
and frozen is so that when you bite into
it you're not biting into this solid,
dense like ice cube, right?
If you were to take those same flavors and
not whip it and put it in the freezer and
you were to bite into it,
it would be a terrible experience.
But because it's so
light, it just kind of gives way to you
and it melts very quickly in your mouth.
And that's a nice sensation.
This is a winter melon that
I'm trying to break apart.
We clean up the winter melon, we take
the seeds, we take the rind off, and
we cut it into small pieces that we braise
in a little bit of chrysanthemum tea.
So it is actually kinda savory.
It's sweet, but
it's still somewhat savory.
And chrysanthemum is a pretty delicate
flavor, especially the flowers, so
we wanna combine it with something that is
not too assertive like winter melon, and
then a little bit of fresh cream.
So we cook that down here, and
then we end up with this kind of
cold, almost puree sauce of winter
melon that still has some texture.
This is some oil being mixed with
the greens of the chrysanthemum,
not the petals, but the greens.
And we'll make a really bright,
flavorful herbal oil, and
so we put a little bit of that
green chrysanthemum oil down first.
And then, after the whipped meringue and
cream has been frozen,
we can take it out of the molds and
we can put it here.
And that thing is so light,
it probably weighs like maybe five grams.
And then some of the braised winter melon,
and all this is served very cold.
And then, we took some of
the chrysanthemum tea liquid,
sweetened it, thickened it a little bit so
it comes as glaze on top, and
then we finish with some
candied chrysanthemum flowers.
So that's the last dish.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Corey Lee: Thank you.
>> Dave Weitz: So we'll take questions,
but let me start.
So Corey, maybe you could explain, you
don't think of foams and emulsions, but
what do you think of when you use them?
>> Corey Lee: I think of the experience
that someone will have texturally.
I think that when you have a foam,
it really does effect how things taste.
And if you have something that's really
refreshing, let's say a lemonade, for
example, and you were to turn that into
a foam and you're really thirsty and
you wanna have this great refreshing
glass of lemonade, it's gonna be not
as refreshing, and it's sure gonna affect
how you perceive that cup of lemonade.
The same thing with an emulsion.
Again, if you have a lemonade and
you wanna add to that
a little bit of oil on top and you have
them just like that, it'll be broken.
But if you were to emulsify it together,
drinking that
will be a totally different experience.
>> Dave Weitz: All right, so
you're taking two fluids and
you're making it from
something that just flows like a liquid
into something that's more solid-like.
But it's not so solid like that, so
you can bite, you can chew it,
you can just break it with your tongue.
So it's a very, very soft solid, and
that's the amazing thing about these.
Okay, so let's thank Corey one more time.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Corey Lee: Thank you.